[Music]
i'm tatiana bartel i'm a phd
student here at the helmholtz center in
berlin and i'm working in the field of
structural biology
and our world is a three-dimensional
world so in our research we try to
figure out the three-dimensional
structure of proteins which are the
smallest units of the cell
and by knowing their appearance we can
also try to find out how they work
[Music]
proteins are basically doing everything
in the cell so we also have of course
the dna
which carries the genetic information
but everything that gets this kind of
blueprint into action are the proteins
they take care of all the processes in
the cell
for example they break down our food
they
take care that our immune system
functions they transport substances from
one part to another they take care of
our skin's flexibility and stability
they're responsible for our sight and
smell and so on and so on
so they are the workhorses of our cells
and when we can understand how these
proteins work we can also understand how
the organism works
[Music]
so we want to find out the
three-dimensional structure of proteins
this basically means that we want to
find out the positions of the thousands
of atoms that make up a protein
where they are in relation to each other
in order to get our three-dimensional
structural information
the protein needs to form crystals and
this happens in the way that billions of
proteins need to order
themselves into a repetitive way and
thus we get a crystal that we can then
irradiate with x-ray light
[Music]
besi2 we need for the high intense x-ray
light
the c2 is an electron storage ring it
gives
us a light of a lot of
different energies and we cut out one
portion of the spectrum
the high intensity x-ray light which we
use then to irradiate our
protein crystals these protein crystals
when we radiate them with high intensity
x-ray light
and we get so-called diffraction images
out of them
which are then evaluated with complex
computation
processes and when we calculate our
structure of the protein from these
processes
we can also display them and with the
structural knowledge we have then of the
protein we can try to understand how
they work and then also intervene their
function
[Music]
so we have to get the proteins that we
work with out of some cells
and when we have them we put them in
certain solutions
so that they form these protein crystals
and these protein crystals we then have
to
mount onto a special machine here at
bessie ii
where we can put it directly into the
x-ray beam
this hits then a detector which then has
these diffraction images
and the diffraction images are then
brought to different
computation programs where they are
evaluated and in the end we can solve
the protein structure
and display it as a kind of model
[Music]
as i said before when we know the
appearance of proteins we can
understand how they work and then also
intervene in their function
this is very important for example what
we
did in our project in the spring of this
year
where we investigated a protein of the
of the sars crop2 the main protease
which is called
empro this is a very important protein
that the virus needs to multiply so we
try to intervene there
with our structural knowledge we have of
the protein
we can study different molecules that
intervene the function of it
and this hopefully we can gain an active
substance or even a drug in the end
yes we did find something but it's still
an ongoing investigation so i cannot
talk more about it
[Music]
so um in our case we approached a
lab that we already knew that worked for
several years already on coronaviruses
and
also now on the zarzkov ii and we
made a collaboration with them so we
combine our knowledge that
we and they have and our facility to
get a novel drug in the end so they send
us the protein the m pro
we do here several experiments as i
described before that we
solve the structure with different
molecules
and this all this information then we
passed on to the
other lab again and they continue now
the work
first of all i want to make clear again
that we work here on drugs and not
vaccines
so there are two entirely different
approaches
you administer vaccines for healthy
people to protect them from infection
and drugs you administer to patients to
help them recover from a disease
we basically do the first step in the
whole drug development process
so we take our target protein we search
for starting points to develop a drug
and then the other labs continue this
work to get it into an active substance
in the end
basically also the whole h3p helmet
center in berlin
gathered all the energy we could and we
all already started um
directly to investigate this protein
that i told you before the m
pro so actually we were here in a kind
of shutdown period
but hdb made it possible for us to start
up the machine again in a
time where it usually shouldn't start up
and we could
do our work here as i said we get the
protein from another lab
so we could investigate this protein
with different small molecules
and then we could give this information
back to our collaboration partner
that they continue working on it
[Music]
so for the zaskov2 project we now
collaborate with german laboratories
but for our usual projects we do here we
collaborate with laboratories all over
europe and also beyond for example we
also have a lab that we collaborate
with in israel and mainly we
provide them with expertise from our
side and also help them in the first
steps
for example to find starting points for
drug development or also solving
novel structures
[Music]
so usually in the pharmaceutical
industry they say it takes about 10
years from
finding a target protein to an approved
drug but right now
with a corona virus pandemic
everybody is trying to make this process
go very very fast
and the whole drug development process
can be separated into several steps the
first step is the research phase
where we identify a target protein so a
protein that has an effect on a disease
and then we try to find molecules that
intervene with its function
when we found these we go into another
phase a testing phase
where we test the molecules on different
properties for example if they are toxic
and only then we can go into the longest
phase the clinical phase
where we administer this potential drug
first to healthy volunteers
and then to patients only if we go
through all these steps
successfully we can get this drug
approved by the respective
administration for example in the eu it
would be the european medicine
agency
[Music]
as i said before usually the process
takes about 10 years
so we can only hope that we can cut it
short to a few years
now but it's not really clear how long
it will take
so during the berlin science week we
want to discuss
how we can utilize our knowledge of the
structural information of proteins
to create novel drugs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you